all right James is with us in Ocala
Florida hi James welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave how are you today
better than I deserve
what's up all right that's great listen
to your show yesterday for the first
time and instantly became hooked I think
everybody needs solid advice and I'm one
of those people so that's the purpose of
my call I'm a little terrified right now
because I'm sitting in a position where
I I will turn 66 in one year I'll be 65
on Monday and then I turn 66 the
following year my plan is to retire at
66 my goal was to reach my full
retirement age and try to it's like I'm
not going to be limited if I choose to
work again and be penalized by Social
Security right okay I have six hundred
and forty five thousand dollars in 401k
and Ross and then I totally have 20% put
into my 401k the company has a nice
company match and then I have an extra
one hundred and fifty dollars per check
or three thousand dollars into two three
thirty nine hundred dollars a year that
goes into a loss that I have my broker
take out I moved to Florida last year
and it's really inexpensive to live here
in a lot of ways income tax wise and
there's no sales tax property tax but I
don't like it here it's just way too hot
for me my daughter and grandchildren are
living in the albany new york area where
i'm from the purpose that we my wife and
I moved down here last year was our son
had committed suicide and my wife was
becoming agoraphobic and I thought it
changed the scenery
help her out little did I know that it
did not help her out so I want to work
until I'm 66 and retire and move back
north and I'm just scared if I'm going
to be able to retire with retire with a
little amount of money that I have hmm
what do you make new I'm currently I
make about 75 okay good and is your home
paid for no I have a hundred and thirty
thousand dollar mortgage and I have ten
thousand dollars in credit card debt I
get a thousand about twelve hundred
dollars a month in mileage and the
company gives me a full check for I
don't count that as income although I I
guess I probably could or should you pay
the expenses well like what I did last
month was I saved up three of my mileage
checks and then I paid off three credit
cards I took the highest interest rates
that I had and I paid off those free
cards okay let's say our our process
that we use to to get people you know
the closest path to wealth and you've
got some wealth you've done a great job
well above average
you know money six hundred thousand
dollars I mean that's a lot of money you
did good 645 I know that's good very
good
and you're gonna have more by the time
you retire and so what I would do is
just do a little bit of cleanup around
the bottom of this and that is let's
knock these credit cards out and cut
them up get you some debit cards and
let's live on a cash basis from this
point forward make sure you have an
emergency fund save to three to six
months of expenses and then I've got two
goals for your retirement one is for you
to have a nest egg enough that you can
live off of the income it creates
without touching the principle and the
other one is to get a house paid off
okay so what kind of a price range of
home do we buy an Albany when we move
back well the house have I had in Albany
I had actually purchased for 78 I had
sold it for
3:17 when you move on Albany what will
you spend on a home I'm looking to spend
about 230 I want to have a smaller house
how much equity in the Florida house
yeah I have about 120,000 equity I will
my plan is to put about a hundred
thousand down on a new house right okay
and so you got a hundred thousand
dollars dad on your home going into
retirement that's the only destabilizing
factor in your whole plan we got to get
that cleared up at some point right now
obviously I could just cash out enough
of your 401k and pay it off and you'd
have a paid-for home with five hundred
and forty five thousand plus what you
put in for the next year and a half or
two years or whatever you do here and
you're probably going to continue to
work you said yeah I feel great I mean
I've got job offers for me in New York
even in my age but I I have kind of a
specialized field and yeah I've got
people calling me saying hey when you
come back we want you yeah and I plan on
where I mean I feel good oh so you don't
you don't need the money today you don't
need to quote retire and live off of the
money you're gonna continue to add to
this nest eggs okay so I'm moving back
to New York whenever you want I don't
care you can go now if you want take the
new job you know well I want to stay my
goal listen I the reason that I came
down here to Florida for obvious reasons
but the company was good enough to
transfer me down here we opened up a new
operation in Tampa so I want to give
them a couple years to take and build
the territory for them okay you know you
want honor that obligation that's fine I
don't know to me I'm good so the pre is
though you're in mathematically you're
gonna your income is going to continue
after you move back you're going to use
that to continue to add to the nest egg
not start subtracting from it and you're
gonna use that to clean up the hundred
thousand dollar mortgage and you're not
moving to New York with any other debt
because you're gonna clean that up now
yeah okay so that's gonna put you in
great shape here's the here's your
formula real rough and dirty okay the
stock market has averaged if you're
invested in good
mutual funds that are averaging what the
stock market has averaged has averaged
between eleven and twelve percent okay
if you pull off seven or eight percent
off your nest egg you're safe I'm good
with that really that much yeah if
you're if you're earning to eleven or
twelve and you're pulling off eight
you're leaving
three or four in there okay
see what I'm doing so if you can live
off of 80 percent of your nest egg
you're good and I think by the time you
quit you're probably going to have a
million dollars in this nest egg so
you're gonna be living off of 80 grand
or 70 grand or 60 grand whatever you
want to pull off of it that's where
you're going to be good job